So, the possibility of explaining the mysteries of gravity
and of discovering extra dimensions of space --
perhaps now you get a sense
as to why thousands of physics geeks collectively lost their cool
over our little, two-photon bump.
A discovery of this type would rewrite the textbooks.
But remember,
the message from us experimentalists
that actually were doing this work at the time,
was very clear:
we need more data.
With more data,
the little bump will either turn into a nice, crisp Nobel Prize --
(Laughter)
Or the extra data will fill in the space around the bump
and turn it into a nice, smooth line.
So we took more data,
and with five times the data, several months later,
our little bump
turned into a smooth line.
The news reported on a "huge disappointment," on "faded hopes,"
and on particle physicists "being sad."
Given the tone of the coverage,
you'd think that we had decided to shut down the LHC and go home.
(Laughter)
But that's not what we did.
But why not?
I mean, if I didn't discover a particle -- and I didn't --
if I didn't discover a particle, why am I here talking to you?
Why didn't I just hang my head in shame
and go home?
Particle physicists are explorers.
And very much of what we do is cartography.
Let me put it this way: forget about the LHC for a second.
Imagine you are a space explorer arriving at a distant planet,
searching for aliens.
What is your first task?
To immediately orbit the planet, land, take a quick look around
for any big, obvious signs of life,
and report back to home base.
That's the stage we're at now.
We took a first look at the LHC
for any new, big, obvious-to-spot particles,
and we can report that there are none.
We saw a weird-looking alien bump on a distant mountain,
but once we got closer, we saw it was a rock.
But then what do we do? Do we just give up and fly away?
Absolutely not;
we would be terrible scientists if we did.
No, we spend the next couple of decades exploring,
mapping out the territory,
sifting through the sand with a fine instrument,
peeking under every stone,
drilling under the surface.
New particles can either show up immediately
as big, obvious-to-spot bumps,
or they can only reveal themselves after years of data taking.
Humanity has just begun its exploration at the LHC at this big high energy,
and we have much searching to do.
But what if, even after 10 or 20 years, we still find no new particles?
We build a bigger machine.
(Laughter)
We search at higher energies.
Planning is already underway for a 100-kilometer tunnel
that will collide particles at 10 times the energy of the LHC.
We don't decide where nature places new particles.
We only decide to keep exploring.
But what if, even after a 100-kilometer tunnel
or a 500-kilometer tunnel
or a 10,000-kilometer collider floating in space
between the Earth and the Moon,
we still find no new particles?
Then perhaps we're doing particle physics wrong.
(Laughter)
Perhaps we need to rethink things.
Maybe we need more resources, technology, expertise
than what we currently have.
We already use artificial intelligence and machine learning techniques
in parts of the LHC,
but imagine designing a particle physics experiment
using such sophisticated algorithms
that it could teach itself to discover a hyperdimensional graviton.
But what if?
What if the ultimate question:
What if even artificial intelligence can't help us answer our questions?
What if these open questions, for centuries,
are destined to be unanswered for the foreseeable future?
What if the stuff that's bothered me since I was a little kid
is destined to be unanswered in my lifetime?
Then that ...
will be even more fascinating.
We will be forced to think in completely new ways.
We'll have to go back to our assumptions,
and determine if there was a flaw somewhere.
And we'll need to encourage more people to join us in studying science
since we need fresh eyes on these century-old problems.
I don't have the answers, and I'm still searching for them.
But someone -- maybe she's in school right now,
maybe she's not even born yet --
could eventually guide us to see physics in a completely new way,
and to point out that perhaps we're just asking the wrong questions.
Which would not be the end of physics,
but a novel beginning.
Thank you.
(Applause)